If I asked you what the largest
ecommerce company in the world was,
I bet most of you would answer Amazon
without even hesitating.
However,
that might not actually be the case.
Listen Up,
Ali Baba started 18 years ago.
We never change.
I'll a drink.
We believe e commerce.
We believe Internet.
We've been lead by helping young people
helping small business and helping
empower women.
We will have the future
his value of more than $400 billion in
more than 600 million customers
worldwide.
Ali Baba is an incredible success story.
That's all.
Say the most valuable Chinese company in
the world.
We can say that this company has become
the best representative of the new form
of Chinese capitalism.
Let's go back for a second.
Is the question that we asked at the
beginning of this video.
Is Amazon the largest ECOMMERCE company
in the world?
Well,
that kind of depends.
For example,
we take a look at the market value.
That is how much investors value the
company asks.
Then undoubtedly Amazon is the largest
company,
but if instead we focus on the volume of
sales made through the company every
year,
that is where more goods are bought and
sold.
Then Alibaba wins by a landslide.
Yes.
Salad Baba might not be as popular as
well known as Amazon after all.
It mostly works in the Asian markets,
but although it may seem far away,
products worth a total of more than $750
billion I sold each year through Alibaba
has different platform.
Nope.
[inaudible] of you who usually follow
visual politics surely won't be
surprised by what I'm saying.
Asia is undergoing a revolution,
a take off an unprecedented economic
growth process.
Every week,
year around 160 million people leave
poverty behinds and managed to become a
part of the middle class.
160 million people in Asia alone in the
next few years.
Countries like the Philippines and
Thailand are going to have a middle
classes as large as those in the United
Kingdom,
France,
the recipe and then there's China.
He's middle class is absolutely
exploding.
It's taking off almost vertical.
Okay.
What happens when a person leaves
poverty behind and becomes a part of the
middle class?
Well,
among other things,
it means they now have much more money
just fence.
This explains why their trainees retail
market is multiplied by four in the last
five years and why forecasts indicates
that the growth Chinese consumption in
the next three to four years will be
greater than everything the British or
Germans consume today.
Do you know who holds both in 70% of the
share in China's ecommerce sector and is
very well positioned in the other
fastest growing Asian countries?
Yup.
That's Alibaba to partnerships with
Alibaba.
Canadian producers have been able to
sell their innovative technologies,
apparel and quality fresh food to almost
half a billion Chinese customers.
I'm sure by now you're beginning to see
this company in a rather different
light.
Oh,
we take a look at Alibaba has
characteristics.
It's lice and its dark sides.
Let's see how it all began.
Let's have a look at the history.
Jack Ma's mirror
coleman.
Never the best student,
but thanks to the foreign tourists.
He visited his hometown and especially
to the relationship he developed with an
Australian family,
Jack Ma,
a child born in a humble family just two
years before Mao's cultural revolution
managed to learn English and decried.
All the advantages offered by the modern
world and as is often the case in life.
It wasn't formal studies,
but the small experiences,
the kind we often don't even pay
attention to that fat.
The success of the person who is today,
the richest man in all of China.
I'm 100% made in China.
I learned English myself.
I know nothing about technology.
One of the reasons why Alibaba survived
is because I know nothing about
computers.
I'm like a blind man riding on the back
of a blind tiger.
Jack Ma,
one of the heroes of the new modern
China,
didn't have the opportunity to attend a
good university.
However,
since he learned English,
he managed to graduate with a teaching
degree,
got a job as a language teacher and a
few years later launched a translation
company and it was on a trip to the
United States to perform a translation
service that some friends from Seattle
showed him what was then an incipient
technology called the internet.
That moments,
an idea had jack jacker right in the
face.
I was afraid of touching the computer
because it seemed very expensive,
but they said,
come on Jack,
go ahead.
It's not a bomb.
Then I typed the word beer,
b,
e,
e r and I could see German and Japanese
beer,
but not Chinese spear.
Then I typed the word China and the
answer was no results.
Then I thought,
how interesting if we could group all
the companies in China and create a page
for them,
maybe that would achieve something big
Jack Ma as that's precisely what he did.
After returning to China,
Jack said,
Tata Company,
China pages to list,
classify,
classifying,
thus find Chinese companies.
Something like the yellow pages.
This company didn't have the expected
success,
but Jack Learns enough to be ready for
his next adventure after a lot of work
in a small apartment,
but if he had a team,
had managed to train without virtually
any resources created Alibaba in 1999
and it's now one of the largest
companies on the planet.
Great.
Mark.
Good.
I'm wondering what Alibaba does,
we should ask ourselves what doesn't
because
see,
Alibaba isn't simply an ecommerce
portal,
but rather are kind of technological
intermediary.
In other words,
I'm like Amazon.
Alibaba doesn't sell anything directly,
but basically functions as a large
market where thousands and thousands of
brands,
producers and distribution companies
sell their products to millions of
customers.
That is,
Alibaba is the owner company,
the company that manages this huge
market and supplies.
Everything that brands,
producers and distributors need to be
able to carry out their business from
payment platforms to metadata.
This may be it's biggest difference from
Amazon.
For example,
think about the huge amount of data that
these companies handle.
Consumer trends,
budgets,
types of customers,
purchase,
timing,
et cetera.
Well,
while Amazon uses all that data to
develop his own product lines,
Alibaba shares them with the companies
that operate through their markets so
that they can launch new products or no,
their consumers' preferences better runs
with us,
sell more,
making the market grow,
which makes Alibaba Greg.
Thus overtime Alibaba has developed a
several different markets,
so if you'd like to better understand
what Alibaba is exactly.
Let's take a look at what those markets
are and how they differ.
First of all,
we have alibaba.com
the huge wholesale markets,
perhaps the largest online wholesale
markets on the planet.
That is to see this market isn't aimed
at consumers through this space.
Producers and manufacturers selling
their products in Biloxi,
other companies so they can distribute
them in their countries.
For example,
say you have a store and you want to
order 5,000
red shirts with a specific logo.
This is the place that you go to.
Unless we use Alibaba.
It's extremely difficult,
expensive,
and frustrating to find a supplier.
Alibaba cut out the middle man.
They make it extremely easy to find,
communicate and negotiate with suppliers
directly through their website.
J June businessmen and investor.
Then in China,
in addition to the local wholesale
markets,
which in this case is known as 1680
eight.com
Alibaba has two of the largest retail
electronic commerce or markets in the
country.
Taobao and teamwork.
Cool.
See,
Taobao is pretty much a combination
between Amazon and Ebay.
Yeah.
Practically anyone can sell that
product.
It's a market with thousands and
thousands of suppliers and almost 600
million active consumers.
Team old on the other hand,
is a large online shopping center
oriented towards big brands.
The brands pay a fee to have their own
store,
basically like any shopping mall.
Then one of the,
that's an old crown jewels.
Alibaba owns more than 80% of Lazada.
The most important ecommerce company in
South Asia.
This is a company that operates in
countries like Indonesia,
Vietnam,
Malaysia,
Singapore,
and Thailand.
And watch out because we aren't talking
about something small scale only in the
next two to three years,
these countries will see them
middleclass multiplied by two discipline
us,
400 million people,
400 million people that Alibaba wants to
turn into customers.
And finally we have what is probably the
best known platform,
but most of us,
aliexpress and international consumer
oriented platform.
Well,
these folks are Alibaba has mean
markets,
but the company's activities end that
Alibaba is also one of the five most
important power computing companies in
the world.
And of course it's trainers,
undisputed leader,
and this division is growth rate has
surpassed 100% annually in recent yet
companies such as kpmg,
Nestle,
Phillips,
and sap already use hourly cloud
services.
It also owns Yukui streaming platform,
similar to youtube,
ele.me,
China's largest home delivery company,
which among many other companies also
holds a significant share of.
Why though?
Something like the Chinese facebook,
but just a second,
have any of you heard of Ali pay for
those who don't know what it is?
Hourly pay is very similar to paypal.
It has more than 817 million active
users.
And there's the leader in the Chinese
mobile payment market.
Yes.
See,
in China,
credit cards aren't common at all.
The trainees have jumped directly to
mobile payments,
so when they go to the supermarket,
instead of paying with visa or
mastercard,
they use Ali pay or we chats payment
services.
The two main payment systems in the
Chinese market,
while Alibaba owns 33% of ANZ financial,
the company that owns alipay and also
pate and the leading mobile payments
application in India.
And I've a strongly growing markets.
To give you an idea of what this means
as financials,
estimated value surpasses $150 billion.
Just a moment,
because if this entire online bet wasn't
enough,
Alibaba is also investing billions in
supermarkets and other physical stores
where it has its own brand.
Hema is also the largest shareholder in
the sun art retail group,
the largest supermarkets and
hypermarkets operator in all of it,
China.
So as you can see,
the Alibaba or empire extends its
tentacles into a lot of Saturday things
up.
Alibaba has services equivalent to those
of Amazon,
Ebay,
Justi,
visa,
youtube,
facebook,
and even cough or all in the same
company.
Certainly not bad.
Well,
this is precisely why this company is
worth more than $400 billion on the
stock market,
but I don't think we can end this story
without talking about the future.
[inaudible]
risks and opportunities.
If we look at it,
Alibaba has plans,
very ambitious,
bye.
20 sales made through Alibaba is
different platforms will exceed $1
trillion just 18 years.
The company aims to surpass 2 billion
customers.
Sorry.
Yeah,
that's the goal,
but will they achieve it?
Well,
obviously we can't know,
but the truth is that it has many cards
on the table.
See,
despite this company's huge growth since
its foundation in 1999 it still has
great potential.
No,
do I need,
because ecommerce is growing a lot
around the welds,
but also because everything indicates
that growth will be explosive for many
years,
particularly in this region.
Let's take a look at it.
For example,
China.
Alibaba is a main market here.
The Internet has only expanded by 55% so
there's still a lot of work to do.
We're talking about hundreds of millions
of people who will sooner or later
connect to the Internet and start making
that first online purchases.
I'm not only that,
given that Chinese purchasing power is
growing stronger year after year,
the same is happening with the average
amount of purchases.
See it since 2015 the average Ali Baba
customers spending has grown by 50% in
China.
So if we combine more spending and more
clients,
well,
you can see how enormous the potential
is here.
And then in addition that rob the
countries which belonged to the
Association of Southeast Asian Nations,
also India,
we're talking about an area of the world
that is not only going to see a huge
economic growth,
but it's also estimated to grow by more
than 700 million people in the next
three decades.
All of this is of course,
in addition to the international market.
Now,
hold on a second,
because everything's not so rosy.
Like many Internet companies who focus
all their attention on growing and
growing,
the company isn't actually making much
money.
Okay.
So we're talking about a $400 billion
company that has barely managed to make
a net profit of eight point $4 billion
in the last 12 months.
And that might sound like a lot of
money,
but the market value is 50 times in that
profit.
And that's a lot.
And of course one may think,
well,
okay,
yeah.
Okay,
but so what,
I mean it's definitely gonna make money
in the future.
Well,
maybe or maybe not,
because if the market grows so much,
it usually entails a very strong
incentives for you competitors,
new rivals,
something that is already happening in a
certain,
yeah.
Okay.
Competitors like J d.
Dot.
Coleman does specialty pin duo duo are
investing a lot of money to compete with
Alibaba,
even though they aren't very successful,
they may never beat Alibaba are off.
Maybe they will.
The truth is that the massive water,
it adds more pressure to the markets,
which may reduce the margins in which
these companies operate in the future.
John,
of course,
there's the Chinese government,
which as you know,
is not exactly the best guarantor in the
world.
As you know.
The Chinese government doesn't undoes
things as it pleases and they can even
determine who survives in a market and
do doesn't.
That means that a botched delivery to a
communist party leader could become
Alibaba's worst nightmare.
In any
case,
it's clear that Alibaba is the best
example of the changes that are weld is
experiencing how Asia is gaining power
and how it's beginning to acquire its
own large multinationals ends.
It's something we're going to have to
get used to because I really hope you
enjoyed this video.
Please do hit that like of us,
and if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe for brand
new videos.
Also,
don't forget to check it off.
Friends at the reconsider media
podcasts,
they provided the vocals in this episode
that we're not mine.
Also,
this channel,
this video,
it's all possible because of Patriarchy
and our patrons on that platform.
Please do consider joining them and
supporting us in our mission of
providing independent political
coverage,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next one.